أقول أنني أريد أن يكون شعبي حرًا،
أريد أن يكون شعبي حرًا، سأتصل
بالشرطة، لا تفعل ذلك إذا لم
تتحول، سأتصل الآن،
سأتصل بـ Un، يمكنها أن تفعل ذلك،
يمكنها أن تفعل ذلك  أنا أتصل بالشرطة الآن يمكنني أن
أفعل ذلك لا لا أنا لا أفعل ذلك في الخارج
أنا أتصل
بالشرطة لماذا تتصل
ماذا فعلت بك ماذا فعلت بك لا أريد
أن أسجل في  أذيع أنك
تضايقني حتى أتمكن من إخبار الشرطة
أنك تضايقني أنت تضايقني من يضايقني من يفهم
أنا لست أنا لست أنا
ليس لدي أي مشاكل معك أنا'  أنا فقط
أسألك بعض الأسئلة التي تضايقني أنت
لا تطرح الأسئلة التي
تضايقني هل سألتها هل سألتها لقد
اقتربت مني قلت أريد أن أتعامل مع
هذا المقهى وأنا أفعل ذلك
هنا  لا تقول إنها
ستفعل ذلك، أريد أن يتم تحرير شعبي
جيدًا، سأخلع هذا، لن
أخلع أي شيء، هذه
دولة حرة، إنها تأخذها، لن
أزيل هذا، هذا ليس
غير قانوني